hi entertainment tonight it's kathy
hilton
and i have the pleasure to interview my
sister kyle
akadoogie well now i'm gonna have to
tell everybody what rick calls you
poodle
poodle there you go that's what you get
sharing do you
kathy will say i'm going to tell you one
thing i was talking to you know
and i was like you know what i mean and
i thought to myself
you know what i'm saying so after asking
you many many times
what made you finally decide to
say yes and cave and do the real
housewives of beverly hills
i think you being so persistent
and between getting calls from the
producer and you
back and forth and back and forth uh it
really does
prove with me at least if you push
and push and push you finally win me
yeah no
noted good to know okay all you have to
do is be pushy with you and give it just
be pushy okay good
okay how much do you love me is that a
real question
a lot how do you think i fit in with
this group of women
i think you fit in perfectly it's so
funny because
you know you already had a relationship
with some of the women
but you got to come in and avoid you
know
all the drama i mean you were there for
the drama but it was interesting to me
to see you come in and be like
oh my gosh this is so much fun i love
this
what's all the stress for ladies this is
so much fun right
wait i thought you were kyle i'm not
getting really i get that
all the time with the hair and i'm
thinking she really has it all out there
i mean a lot of people would not say
it's fun well you know me i know how to
tune things out
so who gave better advice before joining
the show
kim or me don't you love the sister
questions
i think that i really wasn't gonna
listen to too much of your advice
because it was only gonna be positive
so not necessarily i did call kim she
was my first call
first of all i wanted to let her know
that i was considering and
she said to me i said what do you think
she goes
i think it's great i think you should do
it but don't lose your temper
yeah i mean we all do though
right do you want to invest in our
friendship like this
i think i have then don't ever talk to
me like that again what surprised you
the most about my first season as an
official cast member on the show
how comfortable you were you know
in the past i didn't think you were
comfortable in front of the cameras
but this time it really felt like you
didn't even
think about them no idea you were so i
mean
to see you coming out you know in your
pajamas and
me coming in while you're in bed you
didn't even care you were just like
i'm fine i'm comfortable with all of
this so that really surprised me
really yeah well i think because we're
sisters too it really
it was like just a girl's trip you know
you were just thinking of it like that
you know which it is but
there are cameras there so i'm changing
i'm used to that though i kind of forget
about that
um especially if i don't have to
memorize lines
who did you think that i would get along
with
or butt heads with
i didn't or go head to head with i
should say
i really didn't think you were going to
butt heads with anyone
i mean maybe some could get on your
nerves
perhaps one one
did oh yeah but i really like her well
you know what i'm gonna i'm gonna pull
an andy cohen and ask you
who got on your nerves the most uh
you're not andy cohen
oh that's right oh no i better not say
that no i would never
say i would never say and let's put it
this way
if it happens again you'll find out
[Laughter]
oh i can't wait for that i put some
drops and i thought they were eye drops
and i put
ear drops in my eyes are you serious
okay so you have quickly become a fan
favorite did you think that people were
gonna see how
funny you were so quickly honestly do
you want the truth
i always want the truth okay because
really the things that i thought were
funny and really fabulous they were
not used on the show i didn't think that
would anything really was that funny
so well the thing is you are so funny
when you are trying to be funny but when
you
are not trying to be funny is when
you're actually hilarious when you're
just
being you which i know that you don't
get that and see that but just like
the littlest things like not being able
to plug in the fan
that was a very funny meme kathy
it the fan plugs in you actually put it
in the
outlet what has been the best part of
getting to spend more time with me
just how much we laugh i mean you know
we have the same sense of humor
yours is a little more naughty mine's a
little more i mean when i
look at the show and i see us laughing i
can't stop laughing
watching it because it's just it's like
contagious just make me i mean we've
always been like that
but you're used to seeing yourself
naturally the way you are every day
for 10 years on tv 11. for me
i have never seen myself it's like
watching home videos
right laughing in hysterics like that
and kicking my foot i mean i have to
tell you
i didn't realize that i was doing that
when i watch the videos i go i laugh and
i watch him over and over
a lot of people have been wanting to see
the three of us sisters together
would you be interested in doing a
richard's sister
some kind of show together with you kim
and me absolutely
can you imagine that i think that's a
plan things could go
south pretty fast you never know
i'm here this season is about to heat up
with tom and erica's divorce
ladies i truly consider you my close
friends and this is why i'm reaching out
to tell you that i've filed for divorce
this morning thank you for supporting me
this will be tough
how shocked were you to get that text
from erica
i i was very shocked because we had just
been with her
in lake tahoe and it seemed like
everything was fine
so getting that text i mean i was
i was really really shocked and blown
away by that it just seemed so
out of left field just because it wasn't
like a build up
and you thought okay it's coming soon
you know
so i think that's what surprised me the
most just
and she did seem to be a little reserved
yet i don't know her that well that was
really like my third time being around
her
well see she's always you know not
necessarily i mean she can be reserved
but she can also be fun
but you know she definitely has a little
wall around her
right so but it still shocked me anyway
so obviously you are the party planner
extraordinaire so
we're gonna have to talk about paris
wedding what is going on with paris's
wedding
what are you planning give us the 4-1-1
okay she is she i have to talk with her
i laugh and say um paris wouldn't care
if there were
you know white teddy bears and unicorns
and balloons on the ceiling
she's not what you would think as you
know right she's not that
bridezilla type she would be very happy
with a petting zoo
and hamburgers and hot dogs how many
people do you think they're going to be
at this wedding
you know we just have to see and
i think it's better to have a smaller
amount
than a huge huge group so you really can
enjoy it
i agree i know but good luck with that i
know that's what she said
why don't we play this game where we say
three things okay okay two truths
and one lie i worked as a dental
assistant
i worked as a hairdresser cutting
children's hair
and i worked as a receptionist at the
waldorf those are all truth
i don't think kathy knows much about
rules so lastly
can i redo two truths and a lie
please because people were confused and
you did two
lies and one truth i got confused
i think i was just nervous okay i
worked at the waldorf astoria in new
york
in the banquet department planning
parties
i worked at perry's pizza
and had a blast and then
i kidnapped a baby that i babysat
[Laughter]
well first of all you you would do that
last one
but that yes that is true you worked at
perry's pizza i still remember
your kyle the burgundy or the burgundy
and it was the check the little check
why do i remember that uniform
so well i was so proud of it and next to
kentucky
fried chicken i'm naked she got in my
bed with me and i was like
no and then i'm hearing chips rattle
crimpling
i'm gonna go to bed in one minute
so the fans went crazy over you coming
into my bed
at one in the morning with your red bull
and your chips
so why don't you share with us what is
your usual
1am snack if you're up and about gabby
what are you out of your mind what is
this
a red bull i'm not a night person that
goes
into the refrigerator after dinner i'm
fine
i'm not a big dessert person i would say
for like the last eight or nine months
i get hungry and i'll start to think of
something what so do you normally drink
red bull at 1am because we need to i
don't i didn't wear my glasses
look in the refrigerator i just knew not
i
wouldn't take wine i just assumed it was
that was the only other choice around
there or something right everything else
was coca-cola 7up root beer
uh so i thought this is something that
you're up to
and then you're too tired of the morning
you i mean that's like you know
i don't normally do that it was funny
because the next day
you you were up from the red bull and
then we went out and you were asleep
you're like leave me alone
i don't even remember saying that so
funny we're gonna go ride our bikes you
want to stay here and rest and be back
in a little bit
i cannot believe you sleep with nothing
on your face okay love you bye
you